this is fast not fiction the two stars
of pulp fiction Oscar nominees John
Travolta and samuel l.jackson
Sam you know what they call a
documentary in Paris I mean they don't
call it a documentary no they call it
Lud documentary the documentary well do
you know what they call it a feature I
don't know I didn't see a feature well
well in this category we honest and
sensitive work that contains wit
substance and truth the nominees for
best achievement and documentary short
subjects are Blues Highway
Vince dipper zo and Bill gut entire
eighty nine millimeters from Europe
Marcela's in ski school of assassins
Robert Richter straight from the heart
Themis Parker and Francis read a time
for justice Charles Guggenheim peril for
pictures and the Oscar goes to a time
for justice charge good man
to my wonderful editor Cathy shields to
Michael bacon for his wonderful music to
my beautiful wonderful daughter grace
for her production but perhaps most of
all we would agree to the Southern
Poverty Law Center in Montgomery Alabama
and Morris Dees who leads that Sara
Bullard and Richard Cohn who take their
life in their hands each year to fight
bigotry and hatred in this country and
to those people who fought the battle
for voting in this country who died and
suffered but we remember by this thank
you
so you want to stick around for the next
award sure this is for the best
achievement and documentary features
which unlike documentary short subjects
are longer and the nominees are
complaints of a dutiful daughter Deborah
Hoffman d-day remembered Charles
Guggenheim freedom on my mind Connie
field and Marilyn Mulford a great day in
Harlem Jean buck mile in a strong clear
vision brutally mocking Terry Sanders
and the Oscar goes to
Maya Lin
a strong clear vision free to Lima and
Terry son
well I'd like to thank the Academy for
this wonderful honor and members in the
hard work but to be recognizing a film
which is about the power of art to heal
and particularly the difference that one
young woman can make I'd like to thank
the subject of this film Isle in for her
extraordinary gift to this country in
designing the Vietnam Veterans Memorial
it's an idea that would not have
happened had it not been for the courage
and sacrifice of Vietnam veterans that
I'd like to thank the veterans for their
service to this country in particular to
that's Jan Scruggs and Robert do back
who had tenacity against great political
opposition to build that beautiful
memorial I need to thank some great crew
members wonderful team great
cinematographers BA Don Lancer and edit
merits composer Robert Charles Bernstein
when t Cartwright my daughter's Jessica
and Brittney Sanders and see times up I
think that times up any a great